bonsoir younès la merci d'être avec nous
la situation est-elle vraiment
préoccupante pour les français présents
au pakistan
bonsoir je crois que la situation et les
très très compliqué il ya des menaces
qui sont sérieuses d'où la position de
la diplomatie française de protéger les
rôtir 600 français là bas qui sont entre
500 et 1000 et et 1000 personnes et en
plus les entreprises françaises parce
qu'il faut rappeler qu'au même
l'existence de 35 grandes entreprises
dans ce pays avec un échange commercial
de 1 25 milliard d'euros et dont on
trouve des des entreprises comme total
sanofi l'oréal sont autant d'entreprises
françaises qui sont présents dans ce
pays est très intéressant en matière on
va dire de géopolitique maintenant la
campagne qui est menée contre la france
a commencé en octobre avec une position
officielle parce qu'il faut rappeler que
le premier ministre du pakistan a pris
une position contre le président marc
rond en l'accusant d'islamophobe et de
mener une campagne d'islamophobie
systématique sous couvert de la liberté
d'expression après on a vu que ce parti
islamiste radical a pris le relais ce
parti qu'il faut rappeler qu'il était
créée en 2015 avec un agent bas
islamiste très radicaliser et ce qui
fait qu'elle a mené une campagne dont
l'objectif était effectivement boycotter
les produits français et deuxièmement le
fait de faire quitter les français du
territoire pakistanais donc je crois que
la décision française est important dans
un point de vue diplomatique mais elle
est également extrêmement importante
pour protéger leur tour 6 en français
surtout dans un pays qui a des
insuffisances en matière de sécurité
vous nous dites le problème date depuis
octobre dernier pourquoi cela a empiré
maintenant parce que
on entendait des témoignages aujourd'hui
de français nous dire bah nous on voit
pas vraiment plus de dangers qu'il ya
quelques mois qu'est ce qui a changé
donc pourquoi maintenant d'abord les
manifestations menées depuis la semaine
dernière c'étaient des manifestations
très très violente d'ailleurs il y avait
deux policiers qui ont été tuées des
intérêts françaises ont été touchées de
plus je crois que la question que
l'échéance qui a été donné par ce parti
islamiste a radicalisé quitté le le 20
avril pour faire quitter les français du
pays c'est une date qui est très très
santé en même temps il faut aussi
rappeler que cette campagne menée contre
la france vient en même temps de la
visite de la cheffe du chef de la
diplomatie française jean yves le drian
à l'inde l'ennemi historique et
géopolitique du pakistan avec qui la
france tient maintenant un partenariat
est stratégique et elle veut renforcer
son ancrage avec des intérêts sur le
plan militaire mais également sur le
plan économique contre l'extension
chinoise dont le tout ce qui est un de
pacifique alors cet après-midi deux
parties et sanni clp été interdite par
le gouvernement est ce dû aux
manifestations contre justement la
france ou l encontre d des policiers qui
en ont découlé
non je crois c'est plus par rapport à la
question de deux policiers mais c'est
également une possibilité voilà pour
calmer et à apaiser l'opinion l'opinion
publique parce qu'il faut rappeler quand
même c'est vrai que ce parti et les
afficher comme étant un parti politique
a radicalisé mais il y en a d'autres
organisations et partis politiques qui
ont des agendas islamistes le pays il
était un certain moment le berceau de
l'été mouvement radicaliser al qaïda
elle avait une forte présence dans ce
dans ce pays la mouvance des frères
musulmans tient également aussi une part
très importante dans le pays donc ce qui
fait que je crois que la maintenance qui
se passe c'est seulement le fait de
calmer
la situation est bien évidemment ça sera
aussi l'occasion pour la france de
communiquer sur son image sur son
capital d'image dans cette dans cette
région quitté largement retouchée depuis
le mois d'octobre dernier
d'abord il ya une campagne qui étaient
menés par la turquie et erdogan en en
personne l'a maintenant on voit que
d'autres zones où d'autres régions
géographiques notamment le pakistan qui
qui sont qui ont une position contre la
contre la france lundi a été arrêté saad
réduire le leader du parti islamique
telle paix dont on parle depuis tout à
l'heure c'est un parti qui pèse c'est un
parti politique important au pakistan on
peut dire que c'est un parti qui les
populistes parce que là le c'est très
simple d'utiliser dans ce genre de pays
et là j'en dise la liste pour gagner des
gagner des voix ils menaient en quelque
sorte des campagnes contre eux surtout
quand il s'agit d'un pays occidental
comme com com comme la france moi
j'essaye de voir la compagne d'un point
de vue plus large que ça parce que je
trouve que depuis le mois d'octobre on
était face à une grande de campagne
contre la france d'abord ce à commencer
par le fait de boycotter est les
produits français deuxièmement il y
avait des attaques contre la personne du
président dela delà de la république et
après on a aussi les intérêts français
qui semblent qui sont touchés parce que
les ennemis de la france a parfaitement
que la france a sans vraie capitale
c'est sans soft valoir sa culture son
ouverture culturelle dans cette danse
interrégions surtout qu'il était connu
dans le monde arabo musulman par secteur
par cette ouverture est d'abord on a vu
des positions turques et là maintenant
on voit d'autres pays qui a réagissent
également il y avait un certain moment
les des pays du golfe comme le qatari
avait la malaisie la maintenance et
cesser le pakistan est donc c'est il
faut vraiment une réponse sérieuse au
niveau du quai d'orsay pour communiquer
davantage sur les valeurs de la france
et montrer concrètement la position
la position française mais ce qui est
urgent bien évidemment c'est protéger
l'euro durcissant français et les
entreprises françaises merci beaucoup
aux lyonnaises sa belle fait l' économie
spécialiste du monde arabe d'avoir été
avec nous